[Musique]
après le tollé déclenché dimanche vous
savez par ses propos prédisant un
incident grave durant la dernière
semaine de la campagne présidentielle le
leader de l'efi a riposté hier en
pointant du doigt la vidéo de youtube
heures pas si tôt sur ces images il met
en scène pendant 20 minutes
l'attak d'un électeur un sou lui
aujourd'hui on va tester si le gauchisme
et par balles et un mannequin ou les
cris je suis communiste est donc ce sont
encore des propos de haine de l'extrême
droite
il aura fallu qu'il y ait plus de 100000
vue pour qu'enfin on se décide en
interrompre la diffusion
les journalistes qui étaient quatre de
vos confrères sur le plateau n'ont pas
repris jean luc mélenchon sur ces propos
parce que pour eux ne souffrait pas
d'ambiguïté ce ne sont pas des
journalistes mais la dernière pluie sont
assez expérimentés moi je me souviens de
jean-luc mélenchon
il ya quelques années hurlant la
république c'est moi on aime on en est
bien loin
la république c'est plus jean luc
mélenchon ce n'est pas jean luc
mélenchon et ça ne sera probablement
jamais jean luc mélenchon le 17 mai 2008
tout ça est tombé en panne pendant six
heures
alors il a présenté des excuses et tout
ça et bien moi je vais vous dire je
trouve cela suspect à la panne a été
organisée pour qui pour le compte de
quoi quel intérêt tout ça pardon
déstabilise le débat démocratique parce
que pendant qu'on parle de ce genre
d'âneries on ne parle pas des problèmes
des français
à chaque fois tout ça une privatiser
quelque chose on commence par montrer
que services publics fonctionnent pas au
genre une fois que ça va être privatisée
vous allez voir parce que c'est
l'entreprise prix mais efficace
amar ghoul pas plus bas dans une partie
de jean luc mélenchon qui parle dans ces
cas là et c'est pas la plus belle partie
c'est pourtant quelqu'un de cultivé qui
a été enseignant et donc il devrait
maîtriser sa parole ouais enfin
l'histoire nous montre qu'on peut être
cultivé et dire des bêtises il ya des
choses qu'on voudrait dire mais qu'on ne
peut pas dire malheureusement
par exemple le déclin de la france dans
ses classiques en déclin au total ment
parce qu'on a un président qui dit qu'on
n'a pas de culture et je trouve ça
triste l'image d'un président de la
république
giflé la république c'est sacré homme
juif lé pa la république
il est inadmissible de s'attaquer à des
responsables politiques
mais plus encore plus encore au
président de la république parce qu'il
est le président de la république
j'exprime toute ma solidarité vis-à-vis
du présent république on peut pas faire
de la politique avec ce genre
d'agissements violents dans le pays
il faut absolument le condamner de
manière manière radicale ça reflète une
époque qui ne respectent plus rien voilà
donc ça a commencé par les professeurs
ensuite ça a été les policiers ensuite
c'était les maires les députés
maintenance et président de la
république
l'homme interpellé il a crié montjoie
saint denis cri de guerre des capétiens
devenu un slogan royalistes
il s'agirait de d'amiante et 28 ans
adepte des arts martiaux et des combats
médiévaux
une deuxième personne a été arrêtée
arthur c et surtout ça te faire
comprendre que les agissements l'extrême
droite c'est quelque chose de
gravissimes sur lequel le gouvernement
ferait bien de s'en occuper
je vous annonce à détourner les propos
qui peuvent être données dans ce journal
monseigneur exemple par exemple propos
qu'on aurait détourné
je ferai pas plus de commentaires havas
city ne vient de jean luc mélenchon
c'est risible commencé à comprendre que
les violons passe à l'acte je suis
solidaire du président en appelle à un
sursaut républicain
nous sommes tous concernés
il en va des fondements de notre
démocratie
je ne sais pas ce qui lui est passé par
la tête je pense qu'un coup de sang
comme ça des mois de galère hélas quand
il a vu monsieur macro ça va faire
déborder